okay so here are my Nicolas Cage bear
jokes walk a walk a whore Papa Bear says
this bitch is to punch it
Bernstein family says hi allow me to
introduce myself I'm woody the
shuttlecock the bear necessities will
like you to get more acquainted with the
ground gummy bears bones in here and
Aaron in your friends sister Rose be
brother bear I hear you've been harness
ain't picking it back yet
Paddington told me we should meet prays
to fish can't get enough of that golden
Chris Bears got the crunch with and the
number one Nicolas Cage bear joke is
hollow yo can prevent not getting your
ass kicked by Nicolas Cage play me a
ball